I am anointing you now.
You will become a biggest person in your family
in this year.
Money will follow you.
I am anointing you for wealth.
Not only that,
I'm also anointing you a candidate of the Jesus Nation.
You would walk with purity.
You would walk with holiness.
You would walk with the fear of the Lord.
You will acquire finances for the Kingdom.
I anoint you. Wherever you are in the name of Jesus,
receive this anointing.
You will receive contracts.
You will do well in business.
You will receive your promotions.
You will move forward.
I say you are advanced forward.
I anoint you now.
Receive the anointing.
Receive the anointing for this year.
In every direction,
in every place you go,
you are anointed for success,
anointed for victory,
anointed for deliverance,
anointed for healing,
anointed for greatness. Receive.